le cluster tic c'est un formidable le
regroupement d'industriels et aussi de
groupes de recherche publics comme le
cnrs et l'inria le cr dans une zone
assez assez restreinte même si on parle
du plateau de saclay qui fait qu'il ya
énormément des changes entre ses acteurs
donc ça crée une dynamique
pour pour innover simplement et moi
personnellement je connais bien ce
cluster parce que j'ai fait ma thèse
entre l'université paris sud et supélec
une thèse en théorie des jeux pour les
télécommunications et c'est via supélec
que j'ai pu me lancer dans
l'entreprenariat et c'est super mec qui
m'a fait embrayé dans un incubateur la
venue aujourd'hui incuballiance avec un
incubateur public et qui permet aux
personnes comme moi l'issue de la
recherche publique de se lancer dans les
meilleures conditions dans l'aventuré
entrepreneurs
aujourd'hui j'ai en plus profiter du
cluster pour mon activité
entrepreneuriale je profite aussi d'une
aide à l'innovation un accélérateur sur
qualifiante et paul qui permet de
financer le développement des startups
nous ce qu'on fait c'est une application
qui s'appelle spread donc c'est
l'application mobile sur iphone et sur
android qui permet de partager
simplement des contenus numériques on a
tout le temps avec soin aux personnes
qu'on rencontre par exemple ça tombe
bien on est incuballiance si je veux
donner ce contenu à mon associé qui est
dans la salle d'à côté
je vois de suite son profil je peux
cliquer sur son image suite il va
recevoir le contenu uniquement parce
qu'on à proximité physique on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir d'abord une adresse
e-mail ou en italie leur téléphone pour
partager je suis même allé plus loin en
partageant directement un contenu à un
lieu et là je peux partager à toutes les
personnes qui sont dans l'union donc on
rend le partage de copies numériques
aussi simple qu avoir une conversation
comme le cluster est assez dense
effectivement on a l'occasion de se se
retrouver avec les autres acteurs du
plateau a à maintes reprises et
notamment 20 demain je le crois que je
peux le dire on a rencontré alcatel
lucent pour voir si on pourrait
travailler avec eux et avec thoreux site
et l'innovation on est aussi en train de
siècle proto 204 vous l'équipe est le
lieu pour les événements ainsi que le
pôle entreprenariale de l'école
polytechnique effectivement c'est assez
simple et dynamique de créer des liens
avec les acteurs du plâtre